all right hi all welcome to clean
testing
i'm jason taylor and i'm an ssw solution
architect you can find me on twitter at
jasontaylordev
so recently i've been teaching folks
about clean architecture as the simplest
approach to enterprise application
development with net core
today in this talk i want to highlight a
simple and yet powerful approach to
automated testing with net core i'll
demonstrate an approach with tests that
are easy to create maintain and
understand and i'll give you the
confidence to deploy your system to
production knowing that it will behave
as expected
so today we'll start with a brief
introduction to clean architecture and
following that i'll provide an overview
of the clean testing approach
next we'll take a quick look at some
testing tools before we dive into the
live demos and this is where we'll spend
most of our time
finally i'll wrap it up with some
resources for those of you who are keen
to learn more
with clean architecture the domain and
application layers are at the center of
the design this is known as the core of
the system the domain layer contains
enterprise logic and types and the
application layer contains business
logic and types
now core should not be dependent on
concerns such as data access and
infrastructure so we invert those
dependencies therefore
infrastructure and presentation depend
on core
now this is achieved by adding
interfaces or abstractions within core
which are implemented by layers outside
of course such as infrastructure
all dependencies flow inwards and core
has no dependencies on any other layers
infrastructure and presentation depend
on core but not on one another
now this results in an architecture and
design that is independent of frameworks
it doesn't require the existence of some
framework
it's testable that's why we're here
today we're going to see just how easy
it is to test a system that follows this
architecture it's independent of the ui
right now we might be using angular soon
we'll switch to blazer independent for
database might be based on sql server
you might prefer postgres you can switch
it to cosmos db without trouble
finally it's independent of anything
external in fact core simply doesn't
know anything about the outside world
and that's what makes this architecture
and design so brilliant it's the
difference between an application that
will last three years and one that will
last 20.
now if you'd like to learn more please
check out my clean architecture with
asp.net core talk which i gave at ndc
sydney last year
next clean testing before we dive right
into the details i wanted to give an
overview of the typical approach
so with the typical approach to
automated testing we have focus on unit
tests
integration tests and ui tests no
surprises there we know that ui tests
are the most expensive to create and
maintain and that they're also the
slowest to run we therefore minimize the
amount of ui tests that we create
in the middle we have integration tests
and at the bottom we have our unit test
now we know that unit tests are cheap to
create and maintain and the fastest to
run and so this is where our main effort
is focused
so generally you'll write a unit test
first
if you can't write a unit test you'll
write an integration test and where an
integration test won't work you'll write
a ui test
if logic exists in the front end then ui
tests will be required if logic exists
in the api layer then maybe you'll need
some asp.net core integration tests
of course with the clean architecture
approach we're trying to keep logic out
of both of these places
but we're here to talk about clean
testing with the clean testing approach
we're going to add subcutaneous tests
into the mix we'll still write unit
integration and ui tests where
appropriate but the main focus will be
on subcutaneous tests and that's because
these tests are easy to write and run
these tests effectively verify behavior
and integration they document the system
and reduce the need to create and
maintain a large number of mocks
in short these tests are going to
provide us with a great deal of
confidence
so what are subcutaneous tests
the subcutaneous tests are the tests
that operate just below the ui layer now
this can be interpreted a number of
different ways so say for example if you
were building a single page application
with an angular front-end and a web api
back-end in that case just below the the
ui layer could be the api if there was
logic worth testing in that api
however with the approach that we use in
clean architecture there's no logic in
the api so we go one layer deeper we go
into the core layer into the application
layer where we have our commands and
queries which are the entry points to
our application
so we'll use subcutaneous tests to
verify the basic inputs and outputs of
the system and this provides us good
test coverage and helps to ensure that
our tests are not brittle we just want
to test the basics
now these tests are only appropriate if
we keep logic out of the ui which we do
with the clean architecture approach and
this will therefore reduce the need to
write expensive and slow ui tests as
subcutaneous tests are going to cover a
lot of that behavior anyway
so let's look at this from a different
perspective we can see in the
presentation layer
that contains the ui so for a spa as i
mentioned it might be an angular
front-end with a web api back-end or
maybe it's just a microservice with a
web api back-end in core which
includes the application layers and the
domain layers
that contains all logic we'll be testing
our commands queries validators and
other cross-cutting concerns
within infrastructure that represents
both the internal infrastructure and the
external infrastructure as an example of
the
internal infrastructure you can think
about the database we'll be writing
these tests against a live database for
external infrastructure think about an
external client api such as some web
service that you're accessing
so these subcutaneous tests that we
write they're going to operate from the
core layer
all the way down to the underlying
database but we're going to exclude
external infrastructure
so just to ensure that we're on the same
page we're going to test commands and
queries
are the entry points to our application
we're going to include internal services
and they'll be configured as closely to
production as possible
we're going to mock our external
services hopefully we don't have too
many mocks should be only used for
external services such as our external
api client
and most importantly we're going to keep
it simple because these tests should be
easy to write and maintain
so now let's have a look at some testing
tools starting with testing frameworks
the frameworks i considered when putting
together this approach were n-unit a
popular choice by many.net core and net
developers it's probably the most widely
used
x unit a very popular choice with net
core developers
next there's ms test we all know and a
lot of ms test i think it's a default
choice for many new developers but most
people are using n unit or x unit now
that's a logo that i created for ms test
they don't have one created a few logos
in the past this is my favorite one so
far i hope they like it
and finally we have fixie now fixes a
relatively
new framework it's kind of a powerful
convention based test framework
now i couldn't test all of these but i
did create many subcutaneous tests for n
unit x unit and fixie i probably should
have tried ms test i know there's been a
lot of work put into it it's cross
platform and fast um perhaps that's
something that i'll try next time
and so which framework did i go with
well while it's possible to write great
subcutaneous tests in one of these
frameworks
and i decided from the end unit
for this style of testing i found i
needed to provide the best support it
was simple it seemed to be a little bit
faster i didn't benchmark it but i did
feel it to be a little bit faster than
say x unit or fixie and it had great
mechanisms for managing global state and
that was really the key for me writing
these styles having those global
mechanisms
all right so now moving on to some tools
first and foremost we have fluent
assertions so this tool contains a large
set of extension methods to allow you to
more naturally specify the outcome of a
test
it also improves your readability within
tests so it makes your tests easy to
understand and that's one of the goals
of this approach making these tests easy
to understand a little bit of a form of
documentation within your system
so not only that one of the greatest
things about fluent assertions is that
it clearly explains the test failure
results you get better results and this
means that you're going to spend less
time in the debugger so how many times
do you see a test fail and you jump
straight to the debugger because you
don't really have enough information to
resolve it and without hitting that
break point i find i'm doing that less
and less with fluent assertions as it
provides enough information in those
test results so i get to skip the
debugger and go straight to resolving
that issue
overall i found that fluent assertions
helped to improve my productivity and
simplified my approach it's a great tool
next we have mock so i don't think mock
really needs an introduction but just in
case it's a mocking framework for net
it's really the default choice for many
developers now according to the repo
it's very popular and friendly
now you only need to check the new get
stats to see that it's popular i'm not
sure about friendly it's never welcomed
me in the morning or commented on how
nice and clean my code was
but certainly popular we can give it
that
so
that aside it does support mocking
classes and interfaces it's strongly
typed so there's no magic strings and
it's very simple to use no prior
knowledge required that's what i love
about this tool
next we have respawn this is my favorite
new tool
like all good things it's either
recommended by or created by jimmy
bogard this particular tool was created
by jimmy
respawn is an intelligent database
cleaner for integration tests what it
does is instead of deleting the data or
rolling back the transactions so you can
reset your database back to a clean
state is it just resets the database
back to a clean checkpoint it takes a
performant approach by working out the
relationships among the tables and
deleting the data in the correct order
it's easy to configure you can set it to
ignore tables and schemas such as the ef
migrations history we'll be taking a
look at that and it supports many
databases such as sql server postgres
and mysql to name a few the best thing
about respawn like some of the other
tools that we're looking at is that it's
really easy to learn and i'm going to
show you a lot in this talk
all right the demos we're going to be
doing today will be all built using the
clean architecture solution template so
this is a template that i built once i
had a really good understanding of the
type of solution that i wanted to build
and how i structured it so it's a net
caller template package you can install
it from the command line run it from the
command line it's using asp.net core 31
entity framework course 31 and angular
10.
if you want to install it you just run
new install clean architecture solution
template from the command line and then
you can simply run.net new ca solution
and that'll create the project for you
today
now we're going to write the demo using
that clean architecture solution
template the only difference is that
i've deleted the test projects so we can
create them ourself
so let's have a look at that now
so here's the project it's ready to go
you can see there's the domain
application layer infrastructure layer
and web ui representing presentation and
down here we have a brand new end unit
test project and it's called application
dot subject subcutaneous tests i've got
a single test we'll run that to make
sure everything's working nicely
that's passed very quick and we'll just
have a quick look at what we'll be
testing today so this is the application
it's got some step
um examples from the
core template i've also added my own
to-do component
this one's a little bit better than most
of the to-do lists you see out there
because it supports multiple lists so
add a most important task list
go back and change the total if we want
to or delete the list
we can add a new item
to this presentation
we can um edit items
and we can edit the details things like
that delete things set priorities all
that sort of stuff
so we're going to test some basic
behaviors on that we'll test
this view
generating this view model will test
actually creating a new to-do list and
updating the new to-do list
so the first test that i'd like to write
is the get to do lists query so that is
this one
in the get to this query so everything's
in the system has been represented as a
query or a command
this particular query doesn't have any
input or it's uh
to run but we could add input later if
we wanted to so we could add some say
filtering
um some pagination
uh sorting that sort of thing whatever
it was that we needed for this
particular query but this one's a lot
simpler
it's quite basic we inject the dbcontext
and imapper for automapper and we
generate a new to-do's view model so
here we generate the priority levels by
reading the enumeration
and we generate the list of to-do's
which also contains the list of to-do
items
all right so i like to follow the same
structure in my test project as i do in
my real projects so i'm going to create
a to-do list folder a queries folder and
a get to do's query test project
so
let's do that now got a nice little tool
shift f2 to add a new file
to do lists
queries
get to use query
tests
actually we'll just call it get to those
representing more of a feature than the
actual class
there we go
okay now i've got a stub for that so
i'll grab the stub so i don't have to
type too much
okay here we go
all right so this is how we'd like the
test to work we basically want a new
upper get to this query we want to send
it away get the result and assert on
that
we want to do that with our production
so
we want
get as close to the production scenario
as possible so i need to bring a few
references for brilliant end unit
uh i need a reference to the get to this
query that's obviously an application
we're gonna wire up
where we have the configure services
method so we're going to reuse that
configure services
services so instead we'll add a
reference to the web ui
and a project reference
web ui and of course
web ui represents the
references the application layer anyway
so now we can bring that in
there we go i need to install some
packages fluent assertions mock and
respawn so we'll just do that from the
command line
so mock
assertions
oh
yeah i should have saved my um
cs project before i did that because
it's kind of created this nasty backup
file so i'll just go ahead and delete
that
and we'll run that again
there we go
there we go mock
and
assertions
and respawn
okay
so let's bring in the namespace for
fluent assertions
yes a second there we go
didn't bring it in let's give it another
second chance
that's better i'll clean up that okay so
we're ready to go so all we have to do
now is implement this helper method
called send async and of course you're
wondering what does send a sync do
well it's going to actually use mediator
to
send this query through
and find the handler and execute the
handler
now we could of course just new up the
query in the handler and run
handler.handle method
but that's going to miss one very
important thing and that's the fact that
we have a whole
pipeline of crosscutting concerns so for
example we have a validation behavior
right here and if we don't run it
through mediator this validation
behavior is not going to execute so none
of our queries and commands will be
validated we've got an unhandled
exception behavior a login behavior so
we want all of those to form part of our
test to be as close to that production
scenario as possible
um there's one other thing i need to do
as well oh yeah
look at these assertions it kind of
looks like we're going to be
relying on some kind of global data
there and we don't want that to to
happen because you know for this test we
might need one less than six items but
someone else is going to write a new
test down the track and they're going to
change this global data and it's going
to break a whole bunch of tests so let's
set up our data here as part of the test
i've got a snippet for that
there we go so now we're going to create
our to-do list and the tutorial items as
part of the test
bringing those we've got a new helper
method add async which will add it to
the underlying store
and then we'll assert on those results
so we're not going to be dependent on
global data so it'll only be if we want
to change it here
so i need to add in those helper methods
to do that we want to
do two things we want to create a new
class to wire up the production services
and to implement those helper methods
and we're going to call this testing.cs
and it's going to be an abstract class
and we'll just put it in the root of the
project there
now i mentioned that end unit has really
cool
value from the global test resources and
using the one type setup so this is
going to be one for all tests which is
really
bringing me here
and
let's just say we've got no away uh a
weight
um so back in our get to do's tests uh
we can bring in a reference to
testing we could say testing.async but
we can actually use the
using static directive
now the using static directive allows us
to access the static members within
testing without needing to specify the
type name so you can see they've been
resolved
over here oh we can delete this unit
test one we don't need it done
so we've got the skeleton in place so
let's um flesh that out by registering
our services
so first we're going to need to you know
kind of wire up the database and for
that the first thing we'll need is app
settings
because that contains all of our
application configuration
so i'm just going to drag that across
and we'll just modify it slightly i'll
delete that one
from here
i need to get some identity server
configuration just to say that the key
we're going to use is development i'm
not going to require an ssl because the
environment
is in development
so i can put that in here
just like that and then up the top i've
got this use in memory databases equal
to true and that's just a little feature
of the template to make it people to
make it easy for people to get up and
running i'm going to change the name of
this database
we'll have clean testing db for our web
ui and we'll have clean testing db
underscore tests for our tests
so that's enough for
now we can go ahead and fire up our
configuration
and so you can see we just use the
configuration builder prints in the
current directory perfectly the app
settings file
nice and easy
and i just want to create this field
yeah we'll create that ourself
there we go
okay next we have the
services to wire up so we'll need the
configuration for that so let's get
services wired up so via services equals
a new service
collection
easy and reference to startup
because view startup so that's in web ui
and remember that's where we're going to
get our
service registration from because it
contains the
of course very helpful configure
services method where everything is
going to be wired up so we'll reuse that
and then we just simply say whoops
startup dot configure services and pass
in our service
collection if only it could be that easy
actually if we were to run that now we'd
get an object reference error and that's
because when it tries to register the
identity services it actually requires a
iweb host environment
so
to solve that because we're not going to
be doing asp.net core integration
testing and having that environment up
and running we're just going to create a
mock
and we need to do it before we call
configure services so we'll do it right
here
so services dot add singleton
mock.org we'll bring in the namespace
for mock
um
i work
environment
just like that
by reviewing the source code i was able
to find that we simply need to specify
sorry
the environment name
which will be
development
and
the application name
which will be
clean testing
that web ui
there we go
okay
so that's in place um
now the next thing is that we want our
test to be as isolated as possible so
we'll use an i server scope factory for
that and this will be quite similar to
how it would operate under asb net core
anyway so scope
factory
equal services dot build
build service
provider dot get service
i service scope
factory
there we go
okay so with service registration
complete actually we'll just add this
field
a little bit of help we'll just make it
static
okay so now that that's complete we can
flesh out our add async and send a async
helper methods
so first we'll grab a scope
oops
we've got our db context
good
and we can by simply call context.add
and entity framework call we'll figure
out what type of entity is and where to
add it so that makes our life very
simple
save changes listen
oops
there we go
all right so now we need a wire
synthesis for a little bit of code from
there
we're going to grab our radiator
and we simply call a white if you will
return the result await
mediator
dot send whatever the request was
okay that's looking good
uh let's run this now and see if our
test passes
just press ctrl rt
it failed system.o could not find
cleantesting.web ui wow
that's interesting there's a guy in the
name
yeah where is the typo in the name
double e
yeah i see that
um
number 38
38 thank you
uh in testing.css
ah this thanks i was thinking where can
i have a typo in the name for assembly
that i'm referencing i forgot we were
specifying the application name is that
dinesh
no i don't know
oh okay thank you very much
all right so we'll run it again
fingers crossed
yeah thanks for picking that up
i would have i would have um i would
have fumbled around for a little while
looking for that one so there we go it
passes um which is awesome however if we
run this a second time now um it's going
to fail and that's because we're
inserting data into the database but
we're not cleaning up after ourselves so
it says
expected result.list to contain one item
but it found two
so let's use respawn to fix that
so in our testing.cs class we can do
that by creating a new checkpoint
it's so simple to create
checkpoint
and we just specify the tables or
schemas to ignore we only have one thing
that we want to ignore
and that is the entity framework
migrations history
okay
so
that's not very clean
there we go
bringing the field for that
oh that would have been another mistake
oh boy there we go that looks good
and we'll just make that static
i also want to add a little bit of a
helper method you know that testing
database already exists which is not
always going to be the case so let's
just add a ensure database method
okay so that will create the database if
it doesn't exist and also run the
migrations
i'll paste that one in
here we go so it grabs a new scope gets
the context and calls database dot
migrate and for that we need a reference
to energy framework call
wonderful and we'll need to create our
reset state method
and so
bring that here public static
async
task
reset
state
and this is an asynchronous method so we
just go wait
checkpoint dot reset and so we want to
run this before every test
of course we could run it after the test
as part of cleanup but sometimes our
tests don't complete sometimes they fail
sometimes we're debugging and we stop
early and so the cleanup might not take
place but we know the setup's always
going to take place so we clean up the
database as part of setup and then we
know that we have a clean state um
whenever the test runs
so to do that we're going to create a
test based class
so i'll call that testbase.cs
and i will paste in a snippet for that
to save us some time
just like that so we've got our using
static to refer directive to testing
bringing the namespace for setup and you
can see all we're doing is calling reset
state from testing and so to associate
that with our test class
we can just derive from test base
there we go so we have the test setup
logic
okay let's run those tests again
so we're expecting it should clean up
the database delete those two lists that
already exist
and um the test should pass
there we go great so we can run that as
many times as we want and we'll always
get a clean state for the database
all right so now let's test one of our
commands so we've got the create to do
list command right here you can see it
has an associated validator which is
going to check that the title is not
empty but it has a maximum length of 200
characters
and that it must be a unique title which
is going to go up to the database and
make sure there's no other to do list
with that title
over here we can see the dto to make the
request just accepts a title
and that essentially it's just adding
that entity to the database
so nice and simple
so let's create a test class for that
there we go so mirroring that structure
that's in the application layer
and i will put in the stubs for all of
those um tests
using static testing
there we go
green and n unit
okay so the first test that we're going
to write is should require minimum
fields this one's really easy to write
but it does something very interesting
and that is it doesn't test the command
handler it actually tests the validation
pipeline
so to have an invalid create to-do list
command we need to specify an invalid
title
and of course if we don't specify a
title it's going to be null
so then we can add
use fluent assertions.actions which
provides a very nice invoking method
which we can use to assert on an
exception
so we'll simply pass the command to our
send async method
and say that it
should
throw
and the exception it will throw will be
a validation exception
and it needs to come from
application common exceptions rather
than one of these other many validation
exceptions because it's our validation
exception
and that's it so if we run that
hopefully we get a pass
there we go so that passed and it was
pretty quick so yeah that jumped into
the validation behavior
which basically will inject any
validators associated with the request
in our case the create to-do list
command if there are any validators it
will run those validators if there are
failures it throws the validation
exception so we were testing that
and that worked quite well
so
we also want to ensure that it has a
unique title now to do that we need to
do a little bit of setup because we've
got a blank database right so the first
thing that we want to do
is actually
yeah no we'll do that one so the first
thing that we want to do is to create a
new to-do list so that when we create a
second to-do list it um
it will um throw the validation
exception saying the title is not unique
so we can use some of our helper methods
and
you know we're choosing to use send
async here so that we can use the create
to-do list command the alternative would
be we could say await
add async and just add the entities
directly to the database but in actual
fact this way is better because it
allows us to use the system that we've
created in the way that it was designed
to be used
and so we're testing a little bit more
just by doing that
so we're going to go and give this a
title
and we'll be boring and call it shopping
so that's going to send that to mediator
if it's a valid command mediator we'll
go ahead and create that new shopping um
to-do list in the database
so now we will set up
ours which will be a new command
so you create to do this command
and of course we
we want it to fail we want it to hit the
validation so we'll give it the same
title
shopping
and now we can use this fluent
actions.invoking helper to assert the
validation exception is thrown again so
actually we'll just
grab that
there we go so if we run that
this will be ensuring that the validator
is checking for a unique title and that
this little tiny bit of behavior here is
working
so that's good and it pass so finally we
want to create a should create to-do
list test now this one's a little bit
more involved let me grab it and
walk you through it
so the first thing it's going to do is
to grab a user id using this helper
method then it's going to
set up the command
send the command
get an id back
retrieve that using the new helper
method from the database and assert on
the actual record that was created
so what we can do is start by adding the
new find async helper method
and of course we'll add that into our
testing helper class
i think we'll put it just here
so it's generic which makes it quite
easy
because we can use the generic version
of the efcor find async method pass it
in the primary key and that will return
the result
so you can see in the test we also had
this run as default user async and this
method allows us to work with asp.net
core identity to create a user in the
database with a valid user id
and so that user id is going to be used
when we assert that it was created by
the right user
so we'll set this up within testing.cs
as well
and grab a snippet
okay so we have this method run as
default user async which calls run as
user async so you see we're setting a
default username and password and it's
using asp.net identity to go ahead and
create that user
in the database
and we set the current user id
to the
static field current user id on this
class
now
the system is going to actually
retrieve the current user id using the i
current user service
so we need to replace the registration
for that service so that it actually
uses this value
which is going to represent the current
user service for us
so to do that we need to first remove
the existing registration
just here and replace it with our own
mock registration that references the
high current user id
so i'll grab the code for that
and here it is so we find the existing
registration we remove it and then we
add our new registration which is a mock
of i current user service and you can
see it just passes user id as current
user id
okay wonderful
that's work okay
now we need to do one other thing
remember after
uh before each test run the database is
being cleaned up and that means that
that user is going to be deleted which
means that we really need to reset
current user id back to null um so that
we're not writing tests thinking that
there is a valid user so we'll put that
in here
current user id equals null it's reset
before each test
so let's go back
and run that test
and it passes so you can see even for a
little bit more complicated tests we're
able to create these helper methods um
assert on the things that we need to
assert on and use a scenario that's
pretty close to the production scenario
which is great
so now that we've got all of our
infrastructure up in place let's create
another set of tests for the update
to-do list
just to see how easy it is now to write
these tests
so if we come back over here we've got
our update to do list command
and um it's basically going to
you know
grab the entity from the database throw
an exception if it's not null otherwise
it's just going to update the title and
save the changes
so let me create that
so we'll call it
update to do
lists
test
dot cs
and i will
not bore you with any more of my typing
and just paste that whole block in
and we'll have a walk through
okay we'll just bring in the name spaces
okay
okay so we're inheriting from using
static testing because that's where all
of our helper um sorry not inheriting
we're using the using static testing
directive
um where all of our helper classes are
we're derived from test space which does
our clean up before each test runs
so the first test we have is that it
should require a valid to-do list id
and so um we can't update data to do
list if it doesn't exist and obviously
this doesn't exist because the database
is going to be empty so we run that and
we assert that it throws a not found
exception
good
okay next should require a unique title
obviously this is quite similar to the
one that we created before
so we're expecting it to work
the only difference being
is that it does a slightly different
check
because it checks to see that the title
is unique
for the
items in the list
excluding you know the current item
that's working and then finally should
update to-do list so this one will you
know
grab a user id create the to-do list
update the to-do list and assert on the
results
so that's it we can really write our
tests in a simple kind of concise and
clear way and anytime we need to add
some new helpful functionality we can
pop it in here
and we can also control individual test
setup and clean up
within test space
and just just to be clear my favorite
thing about n unit was really this one
time setup method because it really made
it easy to manage that global test state
which is very important for tests of
these kind
so let's run all those tests make sure
they're working well
good done running relatively quickly
for seven tests
so let's continue
all right
so now i have some resources to share
with you if you're keen to learn more
first is the clean architecture texture
solution template so we'll go and have a
quick look at that
i'll find it
so the clean architecture solution
template was created by me it was
actually created
a lot last year around this time for ndc
sydney for my talk there
and so basically you know when i first
started talking about cleaning
architecture i was talking about
northwind traders and the sample
solution that i built there but i spent
so long working with the community you
can see you know there's a lot of people
contributing issues and pull requests
and and following this repo that we had
a lot of interesting discussions um and
and we had a lot of interesting
contributions so ended up building the
clean architecture solution template um
because northwind traders was good as a
clean architect for example but this is
much better for actually creating new
solutions you know you get that
experience where you can go
net new ca solution from the command
line
uh you can see in here
we've got a few more tests for you to
have a play with so this this is the
subcutaneous test library i'll probably
change that name um and we also have
some application unit tests and some
domain unit tests there
so there's a lot more that you can you
can kind of see there
next resource we have is the contoso
university resource by jimmy bogard and
this one is very cool it provides an
example of writing these style of tests
uh using
um
x unit so i'm using n unit jimmy
bogard's using x unit and so you can see
how to write it using x unit so right in
here inside of contoso university
integration test so that's a really cool
approach as well
and following that we have the fixie
demo so i mentioned that um i was very
interested in writing these style of
tests using fixie that actually came
from a recommendation from jimmy who
said you know you kind of have to jump
through quite a lot of hoops to write
this style of test with x unit because
it's just not very good at managing
those globally shared resources so i was
i was i was pretty keen to use fixie
actually i i went i went ahead and
created a um dot net call project
template for it um so if you're
interested in in using fixy there is a
there is a project template you can use
um and i think it's just.net new fixie
from the command line after you install
it
um and what i really liked about fixi
and kind of the
fixie demo um is that uh patrick lloyd
created a lot of good documentation
around this approach uh to kind of
describe you know what the goals were
and what what they want to avoid and and
what they want to do better um so this
is this is really cool to check out as
well one of the one of the things that's
really cool in this particular one
is actually uses a diff tool
when when comparing the results of the
tests so that's a fairly nice unique
experience it's worth checking out
so you can see that no matter which
framework you'd prefer to use you'll
have a good example for getting started
so end unit is in the clean architecture
solution template contoso university is
x unit and fixie demo is um the the
fixie test framework um and so both of
those frameworks were a big inspiration
for the solution that i put together in
clean testing
all right so in summary today i've shown
you that clean tests are simple to
create maintain and understand
and these tests were configured to run
the production services against a real
database and that helped verify the
behavior and the integration for the
test that we created
we used testing tools such as mock
fluent assertions and respawn and that
helped to improve the simplicity and
productivity of the tests that we wrote
and this approach resulted in
better test coverage and higher
confidence so the confidence to deploy
your system to production knowing that
it was going to behave as expected
thank you
i appreciate everyone who came and
attended
i will drop out now to the slack channel